good afternoon
on my orders the united states military
has begun strikes against al qaeda
terrorist training camps and military
installations of the taliban regime in
afghanistan these carefully targeted
actions are designed to disrupt the use
of afghanistan as a terrorist base of
operations and to attack the military
capability of the taliban regime
after 20 years since 9 11 the u.s has
spent over 2 trillion fighting a losing
war in afghanistan to put that into
perspective that's 300 million dollars
per day every day for two decades or 50
000 for every one of afghanistan's 40
million people or more than the combined
net worth of jeff bezos elon musk bill
gates and the top 30 of america's
richest billionaires put together that
breaks down to 800 billion dollars in
direct warfighting costs 85 million
dollars to train the afghan military
that just surrendered without a fight
and 750 million dollars per year for the
salaries of afghan soldiers and what did
we get out of this 2 trillion 47 000
dead afghan civilians 51 000 dead enemy
fighters 300 billion dollars to take
care of the 20 000 wounded americans and
another half a trillion dollars expected
to come for those wounded and where did
we get this two trillion dollars from
borrowing it from loans in other words
if you're a us citizen you're going to
be paying this bill back in the future
enjoy brown university estimates that
500 billion dollars has already been
paid in interest alone and by 2050 that
interest will reach around 6.5 trillion
dollars or 20 thousand dollars for every
american so already we have at least one
lesson to take away from this don't buy
the shovels don't go to war yourself
sell the shovels be the bankers that
offer financing for the wars and collect
interest on the suckers behalfs but
beyond that the us's failed efforts in
afghanistan are nothing new in fact
afghanistan has been called
unconquerable the graveyard of empires
so the question is why what is the deal
with afghanistan why is it so contested
what led up to america's 20-year
struggle over there in the first place
and most importantly with the fall of
afghanistan should the u.s call it quits
or should they invade again
this is what 2 trillion dollars buys you
in afghanistan and if you like riskier
topics like this that other youtubers
are too scared to cover subscribe for
more before i inevitably get cancelled
and if you tag me in an instagram story
of you watching this video i'll repost
it follow me at jtrend.io
[Music]
even though there's a lot of bad that
still happens around the world today the
great thing is that even if you live in
a part of the world that doesn't have
much opportunity with the internet you
can transcend the tyranny of place by
learning new in-demand skills that can
earn you a first world wage in a third
world country that's where today's video
sponsor comes in skillshare skillshare
is an online learning community with
thousands of inspiring classes that you
can use to build profitable skills that
land high paying remote jobs like this
class on hand coding your first website
as an introduction to web development
which is what i used to do it's from
rich armstrong who's a product designer
this class alone has over 13 000 members
enrolled 13 000 people taking their
lives into their own hands instead of
settling for the cards they were dealt
with and if coding isn't your thing you
can find many other classes for
in-demand skills like ui ux design
animation marketing and much more the
first 1 000 of my subscribers to click
the link in the description will get a
one month free trial of skillshare so
you can start exploring your creativity
today pause the video and click the link
in the video description to join now
afghanistan has been home to many
different peoples throughout the
centuries which brought even more people
trying to conquer the land over the
years there was alexander the greats
muslim arabs the mongols the british the
soviets and finally the usa
each of these conquerors had one thing
in common their reign never lasted
they'd invade spent a few years trying
to take control of the country and
inevitably fail which got afghanistan
the reputation of the graveyard of
empires basically afghanistan is
unconquerable but what's with everyone's
obsession with afghanistan in the 19th
and 20th century afghanistan was
important because it formed a buffer
region between enemy empires today it's
a little bit different afghanistan is
full of natural resources like gold and
lithium which is used to make
rechargeable batteries in fact
afghanistan's lithium deposits may be
the biggest reserve in the world so it's
not too difficult to see why a lot of
powerful countries would want a seat at
the table and tried invading afghanistan
while pretending to want to spread
democracy or communism the first western
invaders of the country were the british
in 1823 who feared russia would use
afghanistan as their interest into india
which was under british rural their
attempts at conquering afghanistan
caused three wars all of which they lost
and eventually left because keeping the
territory had just become too expensive
a lesson that many other conquerors
would learn
[Music]
in 1979 the soviet union invades
afghanistan and turns it into a social
state and then a soviet union
protectorates the problem was the rural
tribes in afghanistan didn't want
anything to do with this new government
and all its taxes labor reforms and
threats to their traditional lifestyle
and the invasion quickly spilled into a
full-blown civil war between gorilla
mushroom fighters and the soviet forces
and just like vietnam the u.s didn't
want the soviets to spread their empire
any further so the u.s started training
the rebel mujahideen fighters smuggling
guns and billions of dollars to them in
other words the us was in a proxy war in
afghanistan against the soviets this was
accomplished with the help of pakistan's
inter-services intelligence or isi an
ironic note to keep in mind for later
with the u.s support and their belief in
martyrdom the mushadin fighters had the
upper hand but the war still lasted for
10 years and took the lives of between
500 000 and 2 million afghans and in
1989 the soviets threw in the tower and
left afghanistan and only two years
later the soviet union collapsed
cementing afghanistan's status as the
graveyard of empires
[Music]
after the soviets withdrew it left a
power vacuum which meant the civil war
was far from over the soviets had left
behind a communist leader and fighting
continued into the collapse of the
socialist government in 1992. during
this period of anarchy and fighting
between tribes some of the mushadin
fighters committed horrifying crimes
that would definitely get us to monetize
if we elaborated it was this date of
complete chaos and uncertainty that left
afghanistan in desperate need of strong
leadership and that leadership came in
an unexpected form
by 1994 a miss aldo's turmoil a
political movement and militia emerged
by the name of the taliban it was made
up of students or to live from islamic
schools and mushadin fighters the same
muji dean fires the cia spent a stupid
amount of money building up during the
proxy war with the soviets altogether
they had trained around 90 000 afghan
mujadin and many of those fighters later
went on to join the taliban they wanted
to unify afghanistan as an islamic state
and quickly got support from their
mostly muslim neighbor pakistan who also
helped make the us proxy war possible
the same year the taliban was created
they seized controlled the city of
kandahar and in 1996 they took over the
capital kabul and the afghan government
then came a reign of terror that lasted
from 96 to 2001 along with the sudden
famine under the taliban afghanistan had
the highest child mortality rates in the
world the lowest life expectancy
widespread malnutrition and completely
ruined infrastructure the taliban
continued committing horrible crimes
against the men and women who didn't
support them and even deny giving yuan
food supplies to starving civilians
during this time afghanistan had no
running water very little electricity
only a few phones and most paintings
photography movies and music was banned
it seemed like the taliban was there to
stay and afghanistan descended into a
dark age but then 9 11 happens
[Music]
al qaeda launched the worst terrorist
attack in american history on september
11 2001 and u.s intelligence had one
suspect in mind osama bin laden he was
the leader of al-qaeda a former member
of one of the richest families in saudi
arabia and had even funded some of the
mushrin fighters against the soviet
invasion what does afghanistan have to
do with all this well the taliban was
one of al-qaida's biggest supporters and
president george w bush believed bin
laden was hiding somewhere in
afghanistan he gave the taliban an
ultimatum turn bin laden over to america
or the u.s would go to war and pick him
out of the rubble themselves obviously
the taliban refused having someone as
famous as osama bin laden on your side
was great publicity for the taliban who
needed the local people's supports you
see at the time afghanistan was
responsible for 75 of the world's opium
production opium is used to make heroin
and these farmers were the biggest
source of money the taliban could find
to fund their wars so they needed the
farmer's support on the back of his we
don't negotiate with terrorist ideology
president bush gave the order to invade
afghanistan as part of his global war on
terror their first step was to cut off
pakistan's support of the taliban and
the former president of pakistan
remembers the u.s secretary of state
telling him that if they didn't withdraw
support they'd be quote bombed back to
the stone age as with most countries
invading afghanistan the u.s had no idea
what was in store for them they faced
widespread guerrilla warfare many of the
fighters using the same tactics the us
taught them to use against the soviets
with more of an uphill battle than they
imagined the us sent cia agents to
negotiate with the northern alliance who
were enemies of the taliban and got them
on the side of the us after gifts of 3
million in extensive training so much
for not negotiating with terrorists in
what was probably the biggest surprise
the u.s faced almost no opposition when
they came for the cities held by the
taliban suffering a sudden defeat the
taliban turned to negotiating although
their main pressure point osama bin
laden was nowhere to be found in what
was seen as one of the biggest failures
of the war in afghanistan osama bin
laden and his al qaeda followers had
retreated to the mountain caves of
torabora during the fighting which was
more challenging than the us expected
biddan had probably escaped across the
border into pakistan their main
objective had failed and soon after the
u.s turned their focus to the iraq war
and many troops and resources were
redirected there and by 2004 the us does
what it does best to third world
countries it insults democracy in
afghanistan
[Music]
three years after invading afghanistan
the u.s registered more than 10 million
afghans to vote in the newly democratic
afghanistan jaime karzai won with 55.4
percent of the vote but the fighting
would never stop fast forward to 2017
and it was reported that the taliban had
over 200 000 active troops
[Music]
the war against the taliban in
afghanistan became the longest war in
american history by 2015 147 000 people
have been killed with more than 38 000
of those being civilians both sides
failed to take over the country leaving
them in a perpetual stalemate that drain
resources and hope for them all despite
the small victories the u.s could claim
like allowing girls to go back to school
and all that talk about rebuilding a
democratic afghanistan an example of the
us's best efforts was building a road to
link the country's four major cities
just one section had cost 200 million
dollars to build hundreds of lies to
defend and in 2016 the entire road was
deemed beyond repair despite their
different ideologies the us have
followed the same road as the soviets a
little more than a decade earlier both
sides thought that they could just walk
in fight for a few months and set up a
friendly government but both sides got
pulled into wars lasting much longer
than they expected and draining them of
their resources and in the end both
sides failed to achieve their initial
goal leading up to 2020 the us spent
more than 2 trillion dollars on the war
effort with almost nothing to show for
it
[Music]
the world expected america to go into
afghanistan destroy the taliban and
establish freedom and democracy as was
their sales pitch but as we know that
didn't happen a lot of factors benefited
the taliban's resurgence to the rural
locals their form of islamic justice
seemed like an appealing alternative to
the government's corruption the u.s
destroyed a lot of the opium forms that
were a source of income for the farmers
making them much more friendly towards
the taliban and most afghans agreed that
the u.s created a state where the
president doesn't care much about the
people or their problems with america
making more problems in afghanistan than
they were solving and losing countless
of lies in the process the issue became
a pressure point for president trump to
address
[Music]
trump started negotiations with the
taliban in 2020 to reduce the u.s troop
size in the country without any
involvement from the afghan government
despite worries that the government
wouldn't be able to keep control of
their districts he agreed to a may 1st
2021 deadline to withdraw the remaining
troops making the afghanistan polar joe
biden's problem
[Music]
despite u.s intelligence reporting
afghanistan could fall to the taliban in
less than six months after the u.s
withdraw nato and the us agreed to start
removing troops from the country on may
1st seeing the opportunity the taliban
moves in to swiftly take over the
country and the afghan military that was
supposed to keep control of the country
they gave up without a fight by august
5th 2021 the taliban takes over most of
afghanistan and focuses on closing in on
kabul civilians government officials and
foreign diplomats were evacuated and
president ghani makes a quick escape in
a helicopter packed so full of cash that
they had to leave some cash behind in
the getaway car a day later the taliban
transferred power to them and the
control of the taliban is announced many
afghan soldiers who were supposed to be
fighting against the taliban and hadn't
been paid for months were sent home in
cash weapons cars and equipment paid for
by the us government were left behind
without a second thoughts the same
weapons they ban u.s civilians from
owning in the name of public safety they
just knowingly gave it to the taliban
images are now emerging of the taliban
making good use of all that leftover
equipment marking yet another terrorist
organization the u.s had funded the
irony is truly endless
out of all this chaos the only ground
the us was able to control was the main
airport in kabul with all land borders
taken over by the taliban this was the
only way out for afghans who were in
fear for their lives which caused a ton
of graphic chaos at the airports after
20 years 2 trillion and countless of
lives lost and ruined the us retreats
just like the soviets did 32 years ago
afghanistan had now turned into the
islamic emirate of afghanistan
we gave them every tool they could need
we paid their salaries
provided for the maintenance of their
air force
something that taliban doesn't have
taliban does not have an air force
we provided close air support
we gave them every chance
to determine their own future
we could not provide them
was the will to fight for that future
[Music]
even though it wasn't biden's idea to
withdraw from afghanistan he seems to be
standing by the decision as he believes
too many americans were lost fighting
the afghan government's battles
considering the us was the cause of most
of afghanistan's problems one can only
imagine how this may seem like a stab in
the back to all the afghans who gave the
lies in service of the us military or
fighting for american ideologies
the taliban on the other hand seems to
be playing it smart they already know
they have it in the bag so for now at
least they're not doing much to anger
the superpowers by letting them leave
peacefully and by promising to be rather
progressive although reports have
already come out stating otherwise and
at least from their first press
conference they seemed somewhat
reasonable mr mitchell says that we are
assuring the safety of all those who
have worked with the united states and
allied forces
whether as interpreters or any other
field that they've worked with them
as for their talents and their skills
we do not want them to leave the country
we want them to serve their own homeland
as for the contractor there was perhaps
uh he's gone missing uh as reported by
the media
uh we do not have any information about
him at the moment
which is crazy to say maybe even the
taliban knows that they have to at least
appear progressive to not give
democratic countries another excuse to
invade one interesting point is that at
the press conference when asked about
freedom of speech the taliban said go
ask zuckerberg and the taliban isn't
just in control of the country but more
than one trillion dollars in rare
minerals as we mentioned earlier which
makes it no surprise that china is
coming in with a helping hand at this
point i still think it's too early to
tell whether or not we're gonna see more
war in afghanistan if the taliban
provokes the westmore it could trigger
another invasion if the us sees china
and russia getting too much of an
advantage by having afghan on the side
that could also trigger more
intervention we've heard reports of
resistance groups popping up that could
lead to more conflict if the taliban
keeps playing it safe and peaceful like
they've been doing nothing could happen
so subscribe for more updates as they
come up but the question remains should
we intervene on one hand you don't have
to look very hard to find that there is
in fact true evil going on over there by
the taliban again can't really go into
details here search online if you want
to hear about it more but if that's the
case and we have the resources and the
soldiers enthusiastically wanting to
help shouldn't we on the other hand it's
been 20 years 2 trillion dollars when is
it gonna end how is it our
responsibility to save the world and why
should we even think that we can when
the us military has failed war after war
after war
whatever side you're on i think it's
safe to assume that a lot more innocent
people are gonna get hurt and to
conclude here's a compilation of my
favorite memes that have come out of
this
[Music]
[Laughter]
so i am currently in medellin colombia
so excuse the bad audio and shout out to
my friend kevin tobias for having me
over at his place this is his place with
the incredible view very beautiful you
can follow him on instagram kevin tobias
super smart guy highly recommend so i
hope you guys enjoy this video try to
keep the comments rather civil so we
don't get demonetized so try to avoid
using words like taliban and whatnot in
the comments below if you enjoy more
risky videos like this that other
youtubers are too scared to make make
sure you subscribe because at this point
i'm definitely going to get them
monetized and canceled at some point you
can also follow me on instagram
jaketrain.io check out our sponsor
skillshare because my life definitely
wouldn't be where it's at right now if
it wasn't for self improvement and self
education so that's why i love sponsors
like skillshare so that is going to wrap
up this video thank you so much for
watching you've been awesome i've been
jake stay dangerous out there and i will
see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you